thanks Anna
keep him come all these posters on the
walls or from shows I mean I'm not
telling you you know there were in a
show together right there ever dirksen
worth reading
yeah I'm in this one here business is
unusual these walls could talk
what's up cockfight in the back there
smoker you crazy
he's on fight right in the back
they will do fights you know it was
just watching two chickens fight then
huh you know it's funny I had my 21st
birthday yeah it midnight this bar was
there
Mullin you feel this yeah exactly yeah
you're present for all my what what are
you doing what are you even telling
you're doing you said keep them coming
yes obviously wait so we're dealing with
these one would be but then you bring
other what yeah be more specific
no there's really human concepts like
the ones I'm play my finish with one
more the first time is ever been proud
yeah yeah just finish the beer and I'll
keep them coming then it's just to get
warm
I'm called ray gun firing yeah
technically